thomas bonnet bon jour on vous retrouve
donc en direct de washington
on est près de deux jours après le
scrutin le scrutin et on ne connaît pas
officiellement le nom du prochain
président n'ont toujours pas de
résultats définitifs quelques états
doivent encore rendre leur verdict on
pense notamment à l'état de pennsylvanie
à la géorgie ou encore l'état du nevada
dans cet état du nevada selon certaines
estimations de plusieurs médias
américains ça se joue à moins de dix
mille voix d'écart et c'est dans cet
état justement que l'équipe de campagne
de donald trump évoque des irrégularités
concernant le dépouillement ils ont tenu
un point presse il ya quelques instants
[Musique]
nous sommes en train de saisir le
tribunal fédéral du district ici à las
vegas nous demandons une aide d'urgence
une ordonnance de protection temporaire
une mesure injonctive nous demandons au
juge d'arrêter le comptage des votes à
cause de toutes les irrégularités
alors selon les projections des médias
américains joe biden est en tête devant
donald trump et les plus plein par
correspondance doivent encore être
dépouillée dans un certain nombre
d'états ces bulletins sont d'ailleurs au
coeur de tous les débats ici on se
souvient que dans la nuit du 3 au 4
novembre donal trump avait revendiqué la
victoire affirmant que certains essayé
de lui voler l'élection et c'est une
rhétorique qu'il poursuit ses dernières
heures en demandant d'arrêter le
dépouillement ce top 40 at il tweeté pas
plus tard que ce matin et stop à 40
c'est justement le slogan qui est repris
en choeur par les partisans de donald
trump est en face les supporters de joe
biden appel pour leur part raconté tous
les votes
écoutez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'un côté vous avez donc les partisans
de donald trump qui sont convaincus
qu'il existe des irrégularités dans le
processus de dépouillement est
d'ailleurs un certain nombre d'entre eux
ont tenté de rentrer dans ses bureaux de
dépouillement et puis de l'autre
du côté des supporters de joe biden d
sub des rassemblements sont organisés
dans plusieurs villes des états unis
c'est le cas par exemple derrière moi où
quelques dizaines de personnes sont
rassemblées donc près de la maison
blanche propose d'écouter les arguments
des uns et les autres des supporters de
joe biden et des supporters de donald
trump concernant ce déprimant
il faut juste qu'on en finisse et
maintenant que j'ai lu quelque part qui
les ont trouvés plus de bulletins de
vote
d'où vient-il je pense donc que rien n'a
été positif est positif à gauche depuis
que tout ça a commencé
on est heureux et on est prêt à se
battre contre les communistes et les
socialistes
on ne peut pas laisser ça se produire
dans ce pays il est clair pour moi que
joe biden a gagné cette élection
il est clair pour moi que donald trump
veux faire tout ce qu'il peut pour saper
cette réalité et nous les habitants de
new york
nous sommes ici pour exiger que chaque
vote soient comptés parce que chaque
vote compte
on s'attendait à ce scénario ça fait des
semaines qu'on prépare cette
intervention parce qu'on savait que
l'élection allait être contestées non
bien sûr on a peur pour notre démocratie
mais on est aussi résilient ouais donc
pour les arguments avancés par les uns
et par les autres alors malgré les
manifestations qui se tiennent depuis
plusieurs heures maintenant aux états
unis la situation n'a pas véritablement
dégénéré même s'il ya eu quelques scènes
de tension notamment dans la ville de
new york hier soir les prochaines prises
de parole les prochaines annonces
devraient permettre d'y voir un peu plus
clair on sait que donald trump est prêt
à aller sur le terrain judiciaire pour
contester le dépouillement dans un
certain nombre d'étapes
une situation que suivent de très près
les observateurs électoraux
internationaux de l'ol c'est eux qui ont
accusé ce jeudi le président donald
trump d'abus de pouvoir flagrant
merci beaucoup thomas pour toutes ces
précisions dôme abonnés en direct de
washington